the cosmos
when we say this word we usually imagine
a dark abyss
freezing and lethally dangerous
there are myriads of stars scattered
across its endless expanses
from barely visible red dwarves to blue
giants that sear away anything within
their reach
and this image is absolutely true to
life
but it is also true that the universe is
full of amazing and wonderful worlds
they're so numerous that it is next to
impossible to estimate their number
excitingly every planet out there is
unique in its own way which means that
their diversity is simply incredible
and even though humans cannot go beyond
our native system at this point we can
still make a virtual journey around the
most remarkable of the worlds already
known today
we will start off near the tests orbital
observatory which enabled us to take a
slightly deeper peek into the
fascinating abyss of the cosmos
with its help we will visit the environs
of the dim red dwarf toi 700 to make
acquaintance of its wonderful planets
potentially fit for life
after that we will go to the t-guard in
the star to observe the most earth-like
planet of all those discovered by now
next in line is the bizarre world of
gliese 12 14 being which falls into the
exceptionally rare category of ocean
planets
[Music]
then we will reach two representatives
of the most furtive and mysterious
celestial objects
rogue planets
deprived of apparent stars warmth they
roam the depths of space for billions of
years
avoiding anyone's curious glance
after these dark and cold worlds we will
see a selection of various space objects
which have one thing in common
their incredibly lethal properties
extreme temperatures
harmful radiation and a harsh
environment
with all these combined these planets
are truly horrifying
let's get ready
and we begin
[Music]
[Music]
the first exoplanets were discovered
back in the late 1980s
since then the number of detected ones
has increased hundredfold according to
statistics from january 2021
over 4 000 planets in other systems have
already been discovered
apart from these several thousand
candidates likely to be given the status
have been registered
with sufficient evidence from
earth-based observatories most of them
are going to become officially confirmed
exoplanets
the overall number of planets in our
galaxy may supposedly be over one
trillion
from five to twenty percent of these are
close to our earth in terms of their
size and composition
not all of them are in their host star's
goldilocks zones that is not all of them
are habitable
still according to scientific estimates
there are not less than 300 million
potentially habitable planets in the
milky way
exoplanets differ very much in terms of
their environment their dimensions may
be enormous some even beating jupiter
but there are also comparatively smaller
ones close to our earth and size some of
these bodies are hot consumed with
oceans of molten lava whereas others are
encased in a shell of permanent ice
there are planets out there made
entirely of oceans with not a bit of dry
land on them while another's sulfuric
acid drains or diamond snow are
irregular occurrence
various techniques are used for
discovering other worlds
as a rule it is next to impossible to
spot an exoplanet by simply looking
through a telescope that is why in 2009
kepler was launched the first space
telescope designed for searching for
planets beyond the boundaries of the
solar system
the telescope's cameras had 42 charge
coupled devices or ccds with a total
resolution of around 96 megapixels
with a field of view covering about 25
of the sky and coupled with a one and a
half meter mirror of the telescope it
was able to detect astronomical bodies
within 3 000 light years from the earth
in the three and a half years of
productive operations
kepler managed to spot over three and a
half thousand exoplanet candidates the
status of over two thousand of these has
already been confirmed by repeated
observations
it was in this period that the smallest
of known exoplanets today was detected
the diameter of kepler-37b is just
35.7 percent that of the earth the
telescope was also instrumental in
registering several stars and brown
dwarfs
the transit method was used by kepler in
the search for exoplanets this method is
based on observing the star's luminosity
if the supposed planet passes between
the parent star and the observer this
will be noticed in the telltale decrease
in the star's luminosity the extent of
these fluctuations in luminosity
directly depends on the ratio of the
stars and planets dimensions while their
regularity allows one to estimate the
object's orbital period
the transit method requires accuracy in
measurements changes in a star's
spectrum account for less than two
percent and are usually tenths or even
hundredths of one percent
ripples in the atmosphere dust and
precipitations negatively affect results
produced by earth-based telescopes
that is the reason why telescopes based
on automatic space stations are used for
searching for objects beyond the
boundaries of the solar system
unfortunately in 2013 three and a half
years into the mission the kepler space
telescope had several major equipment
failures
in 2018 the spacecraft ended science
operations completely
kepler was the first spacecraft to be
created specifically for looking for
exoplanets
however most of the objects it managed
to spot happen to be too remote and dim
to study them in any satisfying detail
that is why the next space research
complex had slightly different
parameters
kepler was succeeded by the test
telescope launched by nasa on the 18th
of april 2018.
its main object was searching for rocky
exoplanets orbiting the brightest stars
within 200 light years from the sun
this telescope also used the transit
method and here is the spacecraft's
brief profile tess is equipped with four
refractors with a 24 by 24 degree field
of view and a 10 centimeter aperture
the spacecraft's peculiar raw bit allows
it to cover both the northern and the
southern parts of the sky which is
approximately 85 percent of the entire
sky
photos are taken by four cameras
and the resolution of each camera's ccd
is 16.8 megapixels
toi 700d is one of the most notable
objects discovered by tess
this exoplanet became the first object
of the kind comparable to the earth and
size and which found itself in the
habitable zone of its star
it orbits toi 700 a red dwarf lying
slightly over a hundred light years away
from the sun
it is a small and rather cold star its
temperature is half that of the sun and
its mass and radius are just 40 percent
those of the sun
toi 700 is peculiar for its high
stability
not a single flare has been registered
on it since the beginning of
observations
a star's stability is a positive feature
because bursts of activity are able to
divest its planets of their atmospheres
and be generally pernicious for
potential life on planet surfaces
there are at least three planets
orbiting toi 700 the one closest to it
toi 700b
is comparable to the earth in size
its mass is approximately 1.07 times
that of our planet and its radius
differs from that of the earth by not
more than 2 percent
unfortunately toi 700b is too close to
its host star
it is within about 0.06 astronomical
units and a year on the planet lasts
just 10 days
in addition to that chances are it is
tidally locked that is it faces the star
with one in the same side
this means that the planet is likely to
be scorching hot
the planet lying further from its star
toi 700c
is thought to be a mini neptune
its mass may be from 5 to 13 times that
of our earth and its radius is two or
three times that of the earth
it takes toi 700c 16 days to complete
one orbit around its host's star
located closer to the star than the
inner border of the habitable zone it
must be too hot for life to originate
and evolve there
toi 700d is the third and at this point
the remotest planet in the system
discovered by now it takes
37.4 days to complete a full orbit
which by the way lies along the inner
edge of the habitable zone
the mass of toi 700d hasn't been gauged
precisely and may be anything from one
to three times that of the earth at the
same time the planet's radius is just 20
to 30 percent bigger than that of the
earth
toi 700d is thought to be a rocky world
but its exact composition is not yet
known
the amount of energy received by the
planet from its star is 86 that of the
amount we receive from the sun
assuming the planet's atmosphere is
similar to ours the steady state
temperature on the surface of toi 700d
is estimated at
268.8 kelvin or 4.3 degrees celsius
below zero
however due to the greenhouse effect or
other features of the atmosphere we may
not know yet this figure may shift
either up or down
there is no precise data on the
eccentricity of toi 700d
but it is thought to be small at around
0.11 as the planet's orbit finds itself
at the inner edge of the goldilocks zone
the planet's eccentricity however small
may incidentally turn out to be
perceptible when the planet comes too
close to its star from time to time thus
actually leaving the habitable zone
still with the year on the planet
lasting slightly over one earth month
such unfavorable periods are expected to
be rather short
if there are living creatures on toi
700d
then they might be able to weather the
harsh spells in a state of anabiosis
alternatively they could adapt or
migrate to less inclement areas
even though the data acquired by
spectral analysis of toi 700d can't be
enough for making conclusions there is a
chance that there is liquid water on the
planet's surface
then there is bound to be the greenhouse
effect too
which will help the surface temperature
to reach favorable values as i've
already mentioned toi 700d along with
the other known planets in the system is
highly likely to be tidally locked to
its star
if this is the case there should be a
stark difference in temperatures between
the sunny side and the shadow side
this contrast could be leveled off by
dance atmosphere but that would cause
powerful hurricane winds
although the main mission of tess has
been accomplished by now it still has
enough resources to carry on operations
the telescope will continue taking
snapshots of the sky including the milky
way plane which is the most challenging
direction for observation
over 2
100 exoplanet candidates have been
discovered by tess in the course of the
main mission
not less than 66 of them have already
been confirmed
apart from that six supernovae flares
have been registered three exo-comets
identified and a great number of photos
taken of small bodies in the solar
system the latters were not objects of
the main mission but are of course of
scientific interest
[Music]
before we set out on a space journey
beyond the boundaries of our system we
have to decide on the manner of
selecting a planet that resembles the
earth most from thousands of candidates
what should be the parameters of this
fascinating world and what should we
take into consideration first
it goes without saying that planets
favorable for the genesis and sustenance
of life have always posed considerable
interest to scientists
however it is no easy matter to single
out suitable celestial bodies among a
great number of those discovered by now
to have clear-cut selection criteria
scientists worked out the so-called
earth similarity index or esi for short
it is based on several principal
parameters
a planet's radius density and average
surface temperature
this combination makes it possible to
calculate the object's mass
approximately estimate its chemical
composition gravitational level whether
or not there is an atmosphere and if
there is analyze some of its
characteristics it also helps establish
if there is liquid water on the planet's
surface and other information
the standard of this index is the earth
with its parameters assumed as ideal and
its csi equaling one
based on the earth's similarity index
all the objects known to us
conventionally fall into three
categories
the first one is objects whose esi is
under 0.5
these are for the most part gas and dice
giants as well as extremely hot or on
the contrary cold objects
this is the category most of the solar
system planets and satellites fall into
it takes just one characteristic to
greatly exceed the maximum permissible
values for a celestial object to be
unfavorable for the genesis and
sustenance of life
let's take venus for instance
the radius and mass of the celestial
body are very close to those of the
earth however due to its close proximity
to the sun and a dense atmosphere its
surface temperature is extremely high
that is why in spite of a close
similarity to the earth on the face of
it venus's esi is not high
at just .44
of course there being any life on its
surface is totally out of the question
celestial objects whose esi is within
0.5 to 0.7 fall into the second category
these objects resemble our home planet
noticeably more
they're mostly rocky worlds with
relatively moderate temperatures but it
can also be ocean planets and even some
large satellites
incidentally a high earth similarity
index per se does not warrant favorable
conditions for life
for example quite often low mass planets
are incapable of retaining a dense
enough atmosphere
while their magnetic field is too weak
to protect the surface from lethally
dangerous radiation
other celestial bodies yet may happen to
be located too close to their parents
star and so get tidally locked
of course all these factors greatly
reduce the chances of life's genesis and
sustenance
as for the third category it contains
celestial bodies with a high esi that is
over 0.7 all of these planets are beyond
the solar system
according to estimates the size of these
worlds and the conditions on their
surfaces are potentially close to those
of the earth
among these planets there is one which
resembles ours most
and it lies just 12 and a half light
years away from the earth
this amazing world orbits teagarden's
star a small red dwarf discovered in
2003
this star is
1370 times dimmer than the sun
this means that it cannot be observed
with the naked eye even though it lies
quite close to the earth
the mass of this tiny star is roughly
nine percent that of the sun and its
radius is about five percent bigger than
that of jupiter
gravitational forces are barely strong
enough to maintain the thermonuclear
reaction in the star's interior
that is why the surface temperature is
just
2900 kelvin or roughly
2630 degrees celsius
as is the case for all red dwarfs tea
degarden's star's habitable zone is
comparatively narrow and located very
close to it
back in 2019 two exoplanets were
detected in its system after continuous
observations of the star's proper motion
interestingly one of them lies beyond
the star's habitable zone and the other
within
the outer planet dubbed t garden sea
follows an almost ideal circular orbit
around the system's center with the
orbits radius 0.045 astronomical units
it is completed every 11 and a half days
it is presumably a rocky celestial body
with a mass 11 percent bigger than that
of the earth
its radius is estimated to be
approximately three and a half percent
bigger than that of our planet
unfortunately conditions on t-guard and
sea's surface are far from hospitable
due to the low luminosity of its parent
star the object enjoys 63 percent less
energy than what the earth receives from
the sun
as a result the planet's surface
temperature is gauged at 47 degrees
celsius below zero on average which is
too low for life sustenance at least in
the forms we know it
still the chance of there being vast
oceans of salty water concealed under a
thick layer of ice on t garden sea as is
the case with jupiter's satellites for
instance shouldn't be ruled out
as for the inner planet it is dubbed d
garden b
it is actually this planet that is the
most earth-like object of all those
discovered to date
its csi is 0.95
which is just 0.05 less than the
standard ideal value of our earth
this celestial body lies 0.025
astronomical units away from its star
and it takes it roughly five days to
complete a full orbit around it
by following a practically circular
orbit the exoplanet is constantly in its
star's habitable zone and it receives 15
percent more radiation from it than the
earth from the sun
according to some estimates t-garden b's
mass is just five percent more than that
of our planet
as for its radius it differs from that
of the earth by a minuscule ratio
which means that the gravitation value
is also quite close to what we're used
to on our home planet
this makes it logical to assume that the
inner makeup of the exoplanet is highly
likely to be similar to that of the
earth
there is a massive metallic core coated
in a thick layer of molten silicate
mantle reckoned to be at the center of
the planet
the celestial object's outer part is
covered with a relatively thin crust of
solidified rocks
mathematical modeling shows that the
average temperature of t garden b is 28
degrees celsius which is 14 degrees more
than that of the earth
this means that conditions on its
surface allow the planet to halve and
retain a notion of liquid water
and the planet's temperature profile is
potentially favorable for most
microorganisms
even though t-garden b is quite massive
and is capable of retaining a
comparatively dense atmosphere the
radial velocities method which is used
for exoplanets detection is quite
inadequate for obtaining any information
about the atmosphere's composition but
it should be borne in mind that a
planet's temperature profile directly
depends on its atmosphere's composition
for example a dense atmosphere with a
high percentage of methane and carbon
dioxide will cause a strong greenhouse
effect dense clouds of water vapor
meanwhile will on the contrary reflect
sun rays which reduces temperatures
we should also remember that no matter
how optimistic the parameters of this
fascinating celestial body might appear
it is not entirely flawless
being in close proximity to its parent
star
it seems that tea garden b is always
facing it with one in the same side
which causes sharp temperature
differences between the day side and the
shadow side
as i've already mentioned tea garden's
star is a red dwarf
and this class demonstrates a tendency
to suddenly flare up
the amplitude of fluctuations in its
luminosity may reach 30 percent
which greatly affects the planets
located close by still the chances of
tea garden bees capability of sustaining
life are high
biological creatures often demonstrate
incredible viability
and their ability to adapt can't but
amaze for example the ocean could serve
as protection against lethal radiation
and sharp temperature fluctuations
its upper layer is potentially capable
of absorbing cosmic radiation while its
currents could dissipate temperature
contrasts
for all we know as time goes by
primitive organisms might evolve in the
warm depths saturated with energy and
microelements
just a tiny chance is sometimes enough
for life to develop into something
bigger
[Music]
the first steps in theoretical
confirmation of there being ocean worlds
out there that is planets fully covered
in water were made back in the 1970s
that is when evidence was found that
radioactive decay in a planet's interior
and tidal forces may cause water ice to
melt and subsequently form huge oceans
in all likelihood similar processes take
place on jupiter's and saturn's
satellites
however these celestial bodies remain
icebound as they lie too far away from
the sun whose rays would otherwise melt
the thick layers of ice
but when we talk about an ocean planet a
slightly different type of space object
is meant
the term implies that the ocean on a
planet's surface isn't concealed under a
layer of ice and its depth measures more
than 100 kilometers
theoretical calculations of these
planets formation and evolution
processes were carried out in 2004 by
french astrophysicists headed by
christophe satan
according to this theory if the mass of
a forming planet is more than 10 times
that of the earth this starts to
actively attract hydrogen and helium
from the gas and dust cloud around it in
this manner with time it grows into a
gas giant
by contrast if this planet's mass is
just six to eight earth masses the new
planet is going to be comprised of ice
and rocks roughly in equal measure
just to compare the mass total of all
water in the global ocean on our earth
accounts for just
0.025 percent of the earth's total mass
in this case provided a space object's
orbit lies far from the host star this
object is going to be either an ice
giant or a cold super-earth radioactive
decay taking place inside the core will
help melt some portion of the ice
which in its turn will help form a
subsurface ocean but the planet's outer
layers will still remain frozen
if the planet happens to find itself in
its star's habitable zone its outer
layers will melt and spill all over the
surface in a boundless ocean
theoretical calculations show that a
planet with a mass six to eight times
out of the earth may have a layer of
water over a hundred kilometers thick
the pressure exerted by this amount of
water may reach 20 000 atmospheres
depending on temperature impurities and
other parameters
this is enough for some special exotic
varieties of ice to form like ones
remaining solid even at high
temperatures
in addition unlike the familiar water
ice these modifications would be heavier
than liquid water
for example the density of ice 7 which
is likely to form in these conditions
should be around a thousand six hundred
and fifty kilos per cubic meter
this ice settles on the planet's ocean's
bottom and forms a massive cryosphere
that envelops the more massive core
the opportunity to put these theoretical
assumptions to test arose when a tiny
and dim star was spotted 42 light years
away from the earth
it was dubbed glieser 1214
the diameter of this red dwarf turned
out to be five times smaller than that
of the sun with its mass just fifteen
point seven percent that of the sun
at the same time glieser 1214 is 300
times dimmer than our parent star while
its surface temperature is only 3000
kelvin or
2700 degrees celsius
there is nothing particularly remarkable
about the star itself
to be blunt it is just another
nondescript red dwarf that looks like
any of the billions of other stars in
our galaxy
however in 2009 a solitary planet was
detected in its environs which was
dubbed gliese 1214
with its diameter measuring two and a
half times that of the earth this
exoplanet is just six and a half times
heavier than our home planet
straightforward calculations show the
freefall acceleration on the exoplanet
surface to be just 91 percent that of
the earth
the average density of gliese 1214b is
approximately
1870 kilos per cubic meter
judging by this comparatively small
value the exoplanet cannot realistically
be made up of mostly metals and rocks as
is the case with our earth for example
but incidentally this average density
value seems to confirm the assumption
that the astronomical body is 75 percent
water or water rice and just 25 percent
rocks thus it appears safe to suggest
that this exoplanet is an ocean planet
the object lies very close to its host
star the average distance between them
measures just around 2 million
kilometers or 0.014 astronomical units
which is 75 times smaller than that
between the earth and the sun
also the orbit eccentricity is rather
high at 0.27 slightly more than that of
pluto
this means that in its perihelion gliese
1214b is approximately twice as close to
its star than when in its ophelia
as for its orbital period it takes the
planet about 36 hours to complete it
the red dwarf glieser 1214 may be 300
times dimmer than the sun but this
incredible proximity to the star makes
the climate on gliese 1214b scorching
hot
supposing the reflection coefficient of
the surface of gliese 1214b is the same
as that of venus the planet's surface
temperature is supposed to be around
393 kelvin or 120 degrees celsius
if on the other hand the surface is
darker the temperature may reach as much
as 553
kelvin or 280 degrees celsius
due to the fact that the orbit of
glieser 1214b crosses the star's disk
scientists are able to carry out
spectroscopic investigations of its
atmosphere
still the results are rather ambiguous
if this space object really is an ocean
planet its atmosphere is supposed to
predominantly consist of water vapor
with some accompanying gases
interestingly no lines of hydrogen
helium or complex substances like water
co2 and ammonia have so far been
detected in the planet's spectrum
it is thought that the outer layer of
the dense atmosphere conceals its true
content from the observer
the conditions on the surface of gliese
1214b remind one of what it is like
inside a giant steam boiler
interestingly the atmospheric pressure
in its lowest strata should be at least
15 times as high as that of the earth as
the ocean and the atmosphere are in a
state of thermodynamic equilibrium the
border between them is rather blurred
no wonder as the density of water vapor
just above the ocean's surface is
practically equal to that of constantly
boiling water
as we look deeper at the lowest strata
of the ocean the pressure will continue
to increase until we reach the depth of
a hundred kilometers with a pressure
value at this depth water will be unable
to remain in its liquid state even at
temperatures this high
and so we will see the bottom made up of
dense and heavy ice whose thickness is
estimated to be upwards of 5 000
kilometers
thus most water on the planet is
concentrated here
below the cryosphere there should be the
core made up of rocks and metals
unfortunately
chances of life evolving on any ocean
planet are rather thin even if the
surface temperature happens to be more
favorable than on this one
this is so due to the fact that oceans
on planets like that are too poor in
terms of micro elements that are vital
for living creatures
even taking into account meteorites that
occasionally bombard the surfaces of
these celestial bodies the chemical
diversity is simply not good enough for
life to originate here
still studying ocean planets poses a
great scientific interest
according to nasa's mathematical
modeling estimates published in 2020
there may be billions of planets of this
type in our galaxy both cold harboring
an ocean under an ice shell and warm
like gliese 1214b
water is one of the most widespread
complex chemical compounds in the
universe and this means that the chances
of discovering new ocean planets are
quite optimistic
[Music]
assumptions about the existence of space
objects the size of a planet which are
independent from any star have been
around for a long time
such celestial objects freely drifting
around interstellar space are referred
to as orphan free-floating or rogue
planets
astronomical bodies of this kind emit
very little thermal and light energy
into space around them it is suggested
that there are no bodies in their close
proximity they could clearly interact
with or be bound to
that is why it is hardly surprising that
these objects are so difficult to detect
the first potential representatives of
this class of planets were spotted as
recently as in the early 21st century
the warmest rogue planets can be
detected with infrared telescopes and
others thanks to something called the
gravitational microlensing effect
as one would expect
this class of celestial objects is one
of the most mysterious and understudied
today only three astronomical bodies can
be classified as rogue planets with a
sufficient degree of certainty with the
overall number of rogue planet
candidates over two dozen
incidentally according to the analysis
of data collected in the course of the
ogle project the milky way may
supposedly be home to up to 100 billion
objects of this class
this may only mean that right now we're
at the very beginning of an upcoming
series of discoveries in this field
our notions of what rogue planets are
like have long been based purely on
assumptions and hypotheses
with the technological advancement of
highly sensitive observation equipment
there arose opportunities to put them to
the test in practice
the rogue planet lying closest to the
earth among those already confirmed
is known as wise 0855-0714
7.27 light years away from the sun it
was detected in 2014 with a wise orbital
infrared telescope
the astronomical body cannot be seen
through optical telescopes as it emits
no visible light to speak of
the reason for this is its extremely low
temperature
from 225 to 260 kelvin
or 48 to 13 degrees celsius below zero
in terms of its parameters it resembles
a cooled off gas giant and its age
cannot be under a billion years
the rogue planet is mostly made up of
hydrogen
however in 2016 the gemini observatory
produced evidence of the presence of
large amounts of water in its atmosphere
it is suggested that water is condensed
into clouds made up of tiniest particles
of ice
today it hasn't been established for
certain how this object came to be
there are currently two versions
suggested by researchers
according to the first one a celestial
object like that starts its life cycle
in the protoplanetary disk of a regular
planetary system
mathematical modeling of this process
shows that of the original cloud of gas
and dust is heavy enough it is highly
likely that at least one planet will be
ejected beyond the system
the celestial object may also be forced
out of its stars environs if another
massive star passes it by or else if its
planetary system collides with another
system
the chances of events like that are
admittedly comparatively small
the other version has it that the space
object was born just like any other star
on compression of interstellar gas
at the same time the mass of the object
proved to be too small to unleash any
thermonuclear reactions in its interior
it goes without saying that in this
manner it may turn out only as a gas
giant or a brown dwarf but not a rocky
planet similar to the earth
some researchers don't agree that these
objects should be seen as rogue planets
and classify them as sub-brown dwarves
instead
others suggest using the term planimo
for all interstellar wanderies that
don't show any thermonuclear activity
bearing in mind today's notions of the
makeup of brown dwarfs and gas giants we
may estimate the mass of
ys0855 minus 0714 at anything from 3 to
10 jupiter masses
this rather falls short of starting a
thermonuclear reaction but quite enough
to keep the heat effectively trapped
inside the planet
taking into account our knowledge about
natural laws we can predict what the
conditions on the astronomical body's
surface are like
for example according to research by
david john stevenson from the university
of california in the u.s gas giants
similar to jupiter don't cool off
instantly after receding from their star
their thick hydrogen atmosphere is quite
reliable thermal isolation while the
dense and hot nucleus made up of
metallic hydrogen can keep the planet
heated for a considerable time
estimates show that the temperature of
the lowest strata of a hypothetical
celestial object's atmosphere may be
high enough for liquid water to be
around
it is likely to be present in the
atmosphere as giant clouds made up of
tiniest droplets
these deductions agree with the results
of mathematical modelling of wise
0855-0740
carried out by a team of scientists from
the university of edinburgh it showed
that the most likely temperature value
of the planet's surface is 250 kelvin or
23 degrees celsius below zero
the celestial body's atmosphere also has
a comparatively warm layer around 100
kilometers thick whose density
fluctuates from 0.4 to 1.2 milligrams
per cubic centimeter
it is comparable with the conditions on
the earth and so it is thought that this
environment should be favorable for
potential organic life
incidentally a planet doesn't have to be
a massive gas giant to avoid freezing in
the cosmos in 2020 a rogue planet
candidate was detected using
gravitational microlensing techniques
and here is the long designation it got
it is still awaiting confirmation of the
rogue planet status and its parameters
have been defined only generally so far
according to preliminary data however
the object is comparable to the earth in
terms of its mass and is anything from
30 to 180 000 light years away
according to our current scientific
notions
an object with a mass like that is not
supposed to be a gas giant and is more
likely to be a rocky planet
this in its turn offers good grounds to
believe that the object formed in the
protoplanetary disk of a planetary
system as the latter was forming it may
have been ejected from the system as a
result of a cataclysm in space or
alternatively under the influence of a
larger neighbor
after that it was left to its own
devices and so became a free-floating
planet
what will happen to it next is
predefined by a combination of several
factors
provided the object's atmosphere is
sufficiently dense it will be reliably
thermally isolated
potentially a layer of ice on its
surface could produce the same isolating
effect
in addition with the object's interior
scorching hot and with radioactive
elements undergoing decay most of the
hypothetical ocean will remain in a
liquid state
if the planet happened to have a moon it
may have retained it on ejection
if this is the case tidal forces are
likely to continue to deform and warm up
the lithosphere
theoretically with any luck primitive
anaerobic life forms may have stayed
around although of course it would be
next to impossible to discover their
traces now
most of the data about the rogue planets
we know today were arrived at following
mathematical modelling and complex
calculations
it was possible to do these calculations
thanks to the tiniest bits of
information gleaned with the help of
orbital and earth-based telescopes
even as i speak a project is being
worked on known as cleopatra
its main objective will be to search for
free-floating planets and other objects
in space with subsequent definition of
their parameters
the project relies on something called
microlensing it is a phenomenon when a
celestial body passes between a remote
star and the observer on the earth and
briefly interferes with the light
emitted by the remote star in the
background when observed from different
angles the moment of transition will be
registered a fraction of a second sooner
in one observatory than in another
referred to as lensing parallax this
effect allows scientists to gauge the
distance to a detected object as well as
its mass and dimensions
an interplanetary spacecraft is planned
to be created within the project it is
supposed to blast off the surface of the
earth as soon as in 2025 alongside a
mission to mars
after which it will enter its own orbit
around the sun
the project will be aided by a
specialized artificial intelligence
component whose mission will be to
process and analyze collected
information the cleopatra project will
certainly delight us with a wealth of
exciting and important information so
there is a lot to look forward to
what is to become of all those rogue
worlds out there
drifting quite by themselves in the dark
depths of the universe
in theory a northern planet may be
captured by the gravitational field of a
star and become part of its planetary
system
but this chance is by all accounts
minuscule
most objects like that are destined to
wander for billions of years through
endless expanses of space while slowly
and inevitably cooling off
eventually
there to be swallowed up by black holes
or else destroyed as a result of a
cataclysm in space never to reveal their
secrets to mankind
[Music]
there are quite a few really scary
places in our universe
most of them are cold worlds with no
chances of life ever evolving there
but even among all this gloomy diversity
some objects can be singled out that may
rightfully be called the most dangerous
exoplanets ever discovered by now
and today i invite you to check out the
most incredible ones
shortly before halloween in 2020 nasa
compiled a list of the most terrifying
worlds
among others they included six
exoplanets
each of these objects environments is
not just extremely harsh for any living
organism even finding oneself in their
comparatively close proximity may prove
to be fatal
the first object on the list is a black
gas giant designation tres 2b
this celestial object orbits the star
tres 2 which is a yellow dwarf lying as
far as
718 light years away from us
let's take a closer look at it
due to some unique properties of the
chemical composition of the surface of
tres 2b the planet absorbs over 99
percent of all the light shed on it the
nature of these properties remains a
mystery and chances are there are some
chemical reactions taking place on the
surface that we have never registered on
any similar object before
and it is these properties that make
tres 2b the darkest exoplanet on the
astronomical map of today
this gas giant was discovered on the
21st of august 2006
with more details on its characteristics
obtained several years later
the mass of tres 2b is 1.2 jupiter
masses and its radius measures 1.27
times that of jupiter
the atmosphere is as scorching as 1000
degrees celsius which gives the
exoplanet a faint red glow like that of
ambis
still in spite of its gloomy looks tres
2b doesn't really qualify to be called
the most dangerous place in the universe
there are many more objects lurking in
space that are more terrifying than that
let's see some more inhospitable ones
here is another exoplanet designation 55
cancri e
it lies in the system of a sun-like star
designation 55 cancri a
this celestial object was discovered on
the 30th of august 2004 by the doppler
spectroscopy method let's look at it in
more detail
the planet's mass equals approximately 8
earth masses and its radius measures
1.875
that of the earth
55 cancri e is tidally locked and so it
is always daytime on one side and night
time on the other
that is why the side facing the host
star is always heated up to a
temperature reaching
2400 degrees celsius with the
temperature on the night side 1 300
degrees celsius
these values are so high because the
distance between the planet and its
parent star is just
0.0183 astronomical units
besides volcanism on 55 cancri e which
is thought likely to be there causes
dust clouds emissions
these clouds trap hate and effectively
prevent it from escaping into space
the planet's orbital period is slightly
under 18 hours
as for the atmospherical makeup there is
helium and hydrogen registered in it
there are also large amounts of carbon
incidentally this element is likely to
form thick layers of graphite and
diamonds in the planet's interior
55 concrete e isn't the only object in
the planetary system of its host star
there are four other celestial objects
orbiting it the environments on these
are by far more hospitable
which is the feature by which the 55
cancri a system differs from the
following object
it is dubbed poltergeist or psr
plus 12c
this is an exoplanet lying in a pulsar
system
the celestial object is located just
0.36 astronomical units from the
system's center
this shows that poltergeist wouldn't
have survived a supernova that must have
taken place before the pulsar had been
formed
consequently the exoplanet is likely to
have formed after this tremendous event
with the material for it coming from the
nebula left after the explosion
according to another hypothesis the
pulsar may have formed after the merging
of two white dwarfs
unlike with a supernova this process
isn't always accompanied by a powerful
blast
still as this is the first object of its
kind we have discovered science cannot
give a definite answer as to its origins
the system with a celestial object lies
300 light years from the earth
its mass is approximately four times
that of our planet
as for its orbital period it is around
66 days
incidentally the outstandingly powerful
radiation emitted by the pulsar is
enough to crumple any spaceship wanting
to approach the mysterious exoplanet in
its system
even with all these properties taken
into account poltergeist does not really
qualify as the most dangerous exoplanet
known to us
on approaching it an astronomical body
may simply get destroyed but it would
get positively vaporized in close
proximity to the following object
the reason for this effect is the
extremely high temperature on kepler-70b
which is the hottest exoplanet known to
us
the object orbits the sub-dwarf star
kepler-70
with a surface temperature higher than
that on our sun it reaches
6800 degrees celsius
the object's mass equals 0.44 earth
masses and its radius measures 0.76 that
of the earth
the celestial object's orbital period is
345 minutes
in other words a day here is less than 6
hours long
interestingly the exoplanet regularly
passes another object in the system
kepler-70c at a distance of 240 000
kilometers
to date this is the closest that planets
in space have been registered to pass
each other
the extremely high temperature on
kepler-70b could be accounted for by the
fact that this object may once have been
part of its parent star
as for giving it the status of an
exoplanet it will take more evidence to
confirm that it deserves to be given it
so this remains an open question
it should be mentioned that kepler-70b
is not the only celestial object we know
of that interacts with its parent star
so closely
another object in similar conditions is
the exoplanet known as wasp 12b
this celestial body lies
870 light years away from our system its
radius measures
1.93 times that of jupiter and its mass
equals 1.46 jupiter masses
wasp 12b is just 0.03 astronomical units
away from its parent star
due to this close proximity the
exoplanet has a temperature reaching as
much as
2200 degrees celsius
the host star's extremely powerful
gravitation slowly absorbs wasp
12b eventually in approximately 10
million years time the exoplanet is
expected to be destroyed completely
bearing all this in mind we will
probably never delve any deeper into the
nature of this exoplanet it would appear
that studying worlds of this kind cannot
be high on scientists list of priorities
however some of these objects may happen
to have some really unique features
seemingly quite plain and ordinary
worlds like that may conceal many more
dangers than would appear at first
glance
when flying past the celestial body
hd189733b for example one might
complacently think it a safe planet as
it resembles our earth by its looks
but if one were to get as low as the
level of its atmosphere one would be
exposed to some life-threatening dangers
for a start the object's winds carry
particles of silicate and develop
velocities of 8
700 kilometers per hour
besides the rains on this planet cause
precipitations of molten glass
the reasons for such hazardous weather
conditions are extremely high
temperatures and the atmosphere's
peculiar chemical composition
speaking about the exoplanet's orbital
period it is approximately 2.5 days
and it is highly likely that the object
is tidally locked to its parent star
[Music]
as usual a quick overview of its main
characteristics
hd189733b is a bright blue gas giant
orbiting an orange dwarf in the
constellation vulpecula it lies just 63
light years away from our system
the object's diameter is 1.1 times that
of jupiter and as for its mass it is
113 percent that of jupiter
interestingly the distance between
hd189733b
and its star is 30 times less than the
distance between the earth and the sun
and equals approximately 5 million
kilometers
due to its close proximity to the parent
star it has a constant surface
temperature of as high as around
930 degrees celsius on the dayside with
the temperature on the night side never
dropping below
425 degrees celsius
immediately on being discovered the
celestial body became a subject of
investigations
in 2007 thanks to data obtained by the
hubble telescope scientists found out
that hd189733b
has a foggy atmosphere
interestingly when the planet transits
between the observer and the earth and
its star its atmosphere assumes a
reddish hue
this effect could possibly be caused by
the haze in the atmosphere
according to preliminary estimates it
consists of particles of iron silicates
and aluminium oxide
apart from that the information beamed
back by the hubble telescope helped
scientists establish that the planet's
atmosphere contains water vapor neutral
oxygen and an organic methane compound
additional investigations revealed the
presence of carbon monoxide on the
dayside of the planet
what prompted most questions however was
the results of investigations revealing
traces of methane of an unusual variety
in the planet's atmosphere
this chemical element was shown to be in
a peculiar fluorescent state when it
emits electromagnetic radiation in the
infrared range
this state of the substance is
indicative of some unknown activity in
the atmosphere of the exoplanet
which still remains to be found out
this is quite a clear-cut example of a
situation when investigating an object
like an exoplanet with an exceptionally
harsh environment may yield unexpected
results about some processes taking
place there that will be a valuable
contribution to science
and as the process of studying these
worlds continues
they will remain no other than horror
planets to us as well as a solid
reminder that we're more than just lucky
to be the dwellers of our earth
[Music]
earlier in one of our previous videos we
have already taken a look at some
terrifying and lethally dangerous worlds
discovered in the vast expanses of space
with some of them extremely hot others
are located close to insanely powerful
sources of radiation and yet other ones
are peculiar for some bizarre features
on their surfaces
however we haven't quite exhausted our
list of the most horrifying planets and
now it's time to see some more
our first stop is 202 light years away
from the earth destination k2-141
an orange dwarf
its mass is roughly 0.7 that of the sun
and its radius measures 68 that of our
host star
with these parameters almost perfectly
proportional the star's temperature
reaches
4600 kelvin
which is about 20 percent less than that
of the sun
and now to the planet in question
just 0.007 astronomical units away from
its star there lies a really bizarre
world designation k2-141b
this rocky exoplanet is five times as
massive as the earth with its radius 1.5
times as big as that of our earth
all this gives us grounds to assume that
the gravity on the planet's surface is
at least twice as strong as that on our
planet the heavy metallic core meanwhile
accounts for 20 to 50 percent of the
planet's overall mass it takes the
celestial body about six and a half
hours to complete a full orbit around
its parent star being extremely close it
is tidally locked to it that is it faces
the star with one on the same side at
all times
observations show that the temperature
on the planet's dayside reaches 3
and kelvin or 3000 degrees celsius
this is enough not only to melt most
rocks and metals but also to effectively
evaporate them
the day side of the planet is assumed to
be covered with a lava ocean that never
ceases to boil
the atmosphere is thought to be rather
exotic made up of steams of heavy metals
and silicates
by contrast the planet's night side is
incredibly freezing according to
estimates the temperature of most of its
area is tens of times lower than that on
the day side and on balance its values
are supposed to be sub-zero
mathematical modelling shows that this
sharp temperature contrast gives rise to
exceptionally strong winds whose speed
reaches 1.75 kilometers per second
this is roughly 5 times the speed of
sound which means that the surface of
k2-141b
is continuously shaken by exceptionally
powerful deafening rumbling
it is assumed that on reaching the night
side atmospheric streams condense and
precipitate on its surface in the form
of fiery rain
this forms lava rivers
and eventually the smelt and metal makes
its way back into the magma ocean to
evaporate again later on and to continue
this incredible fiery circulation
however this infernal cycle affects only
a relatively small part of the planet's
night side the thing is that masses of
evaporated elements from the dayside
simply don't make it to the main part of
the night side and precipitate somewhere
on the border that is why the central
part of the night side is likely to be a
freezing desert bound with layers of
solid rocks
remarkably k2-141b
is far from being the hottest planet
that we know of
for example there is an object referred
to as celt 9b
lying
670 light years away from the earth
its surface is as hot as
4600 kelvin which is approximately
4330 degrees celsius
just to compare the outer layers of
almost all red dwarves for example are
much cooler
which means that in terms of temperature
this exoplanet is quite a match to stars
its parent star designation celt9 is of
a whitish blue color and has a mass 2.6
times that of the sun
as for its diameter it is 2.3 times that
of our star
the surface temperature of count 9 is
rather high at approximately 10
107 kelvin or a staggering
9900 degrees celsius
this largely accounts for the extreme
conditions on count 9b which lies quite
close by
just
.035 astronomical units away from its
parent star the planet completes a full
orbit around its system's center roughly
every one and a half days
celt 9b is a hot gas giant
compared to jupiter its mass is 2.8
times as big and its radius measures
roughly twice as much as that of the
largest planet in our system
based on today's notions about the
composition of this type of planets the
inner part of count 9b's atmosphere is
supposed to be even hotter
estimates allow for this value to reach
as much as 11 000 kelvin on account of
heavy metal ionization
with this figure so exceptionally big it
appears that the planet's atmosphere
should contain vaporized iron and
titanium alongside the elements we're
used to in an atmosphere's composition
such as hydrogen or helium
its close proximity to the parent star
and the extremely high temperature
caused the planet to gradually lose its
atmosphere
by and by powerful stellar wind blows it
off into space
which is why the object is shrouded in a
cloud of rarefied gas
this material will eventually be
attracted and absorbed by the star
interestingly according to some
estimates the exoplanet loses up to 68
earth masses every billion years
theoretically in a long while celt9 b
may well get stripped of all of its
atmosphere and transform itself into a
thonian planet
however its parent star is likely to hit
the final stage of its life cycle long
before that swallowing up and destroying
all the celestial objects within its
reach
the space objects we have just looked at
are a living proof as aware of the fact
that stars can destroy the planets close
to them and not just warm them up but
incidentally there are celestial objects
out there in the universe that have
experienced their parent star's wrath in
full measure
one of such objects lies 4500
light years away from the earth in the
environs of a small star designation
v391 pegasi
now the star is a white dwarf whose mass
is twice as little as that of the sun
and whose radius is approximately 23
percent that of our parent star the
temperature of the celestial object is
unbelievably high at almost 30 000
kelvin all thermonuclear reactions in
its interior would have run their course
a long while ago up ahead are hundreds
of billions of years of slow cooling
with the white dwarf eventually
transforming into a black one
the planet we will look at referred to
as v391 pegasi b is in this ordinary
star's environs its slot is
exceptionally amazing according to
mathematical modelling the planet not
only survived its progenitor star
shedding its outer layers but actually
found itself almost within the star for
some time it is assumed that when the
system's star v391 pegasi transformed
into a red giant its outer layers
extremely rarified by then were almost
brushing the planet's orbit
their density became dozens of times
lower than the atmospheric air were used
to which means that the celestial
objects devoured by the dying star
remained whole for a while and didn't
get destroyed at once
it goes without saying that they would
have been losing their speed and dropped
into the star's hotter and denser layers
still
v391 pegasi shed its outer layers sooner
than v391 pegasi b melted and ceased to
exist as a whole object at the moment
the exoplanet appears to be a gas giant
three times as massive as jupiter
its orbit passes 1.7 astronomical units
away from its parent star and it takes
the planet approximately
1170 earth days to complete a full orbit
around its system center it is still not
entirely clear how this astronomical
body managed to preserve such a big mass
after its collision with the scorching
hot layers of the star their influence
was supposed to have destroyed the
object's atmosphere completely
however there is no doubt that the host
star's collapse brought about some
dramatic changes both in terms of the
exoplanet's orbit and its parameters
that is why it is hardly possible for us
to ever find out what v391 pegasi b was
like before immersing in a sea of raging
plasma
space expenses conceal uncountable
astronomical objects with the most
bizarre properties some of them are
almost totally invisible through regular
telescopes but can be detected by
looking at radio wavelengths when
exploring space
an example of such like celestial
objects
is pulsars neutron stars spinning on
their axis at a mind-boggling speed
these objects spectra are peculiar for
exceptionally fast and regular
pulsations that is why it is quite easy
to detect another celestial body
transiting between a radiation source
like that and an observer on the earth
this is precisely the way our next
object of interest was discovered but
first we'll be looking at a pulsar which
lies around 4 000 light years away from
the earth this neutron star boasts quite
a long name here it is on the screen and
now let's check out its remarkable
features the pulsar's diameter is just a
measly 20 kilometers and its mass is
approximately 1.4 that of the sun the
object spins at an incredible rate with
roughly 10 000 rotations a minute while
continuously emitting powerful
electromagnetic radiation impulses
now the surface of the exoplanet our
next object of interest is continuously
exposed to these waves of lethal
radiation which makes it a hostile and
forbidding place
it takes this planet just two hours to
complete a full orbit around its
system's center and the distance to the
pulsar is smaller than the sun's radius
just six hundred thousand kilometers or
0.004 astronomical units
incidentally the celestial body's
surface is bound by eternal code and
space as its parent star just barely
emits thermal energy the object's mass
is around 330 that of the earth while
its radius is four times that of our
planet
this makes gravity on its surface as
much as 20 times stronger than on the
earth
estimates show the planet's average
density to be about 23 grams per cubic
centimeter which is more than most
chemical compounds we know
the planet is thought to be made up for
the most part of crystallized carbon
under a lot of pressure
besides the object's upper layers
contain some oxygen which is probably
chemically bound with carbon
it is highly doubtful that a celestial
body located so close to a star could
possibly have survived a supernova event
it is more realistic to assume that the
exoplanet formed after the progenitor
star had come to the end of its life
cycle and had transformed itself into a
pulsar the exoplanet could be a piece of
debris left over from a white dwarf
whose material would have dispersed for
the most part
this makes classifying the exoplanet an
especially difficult task
still whatever it is
this world remains one of the most
dangerous and hostile ones lurking in
the depths of the cosmos
amazingly
even having covered thousands of light
years we have made acquaintance of only
a minuscule portion of the endless
diversity of our galaxy's exoplanets
hundreds of billions of other worlds
still remain concealed from observation
however every day we find out more about
the universe
and what seemed unlikely yesterday may
become quite feasible even tomorrow
which may only mean that there are great
many discoveries yet for us to enjoy
up ahead
[Music]
so
you